that's that's not a good sound hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to the joy of creation
story mode now we're on the way to the
living room and we got a long way to go
before we get to the end of this game
and I have a funky feeling that it's
gonna end into the Attic of the basement
but with that being said we got to get
through the living room first I was
going to it's going in the living room
and see what happens in there well it's
not like he was in any condition to do
anything did you see his clothes it's
like he came out of a bonfire I mean I
could have bonfire you know called an
ambulance maybe dropped him off near a
hospital would have been better I just
don't think I feel comfortable with a
complete stranger just ending up
sleeping in our houses off mmm honey I'm
worried about the kids or something
about the kids he's sleeping right next
to them how can I not be
what if he's faking about we could stay
here to make sure nothing happens if
you're that worried all night now of
course all night come on don't you want
to spend time with me more you aren't
done updating your site for the
anniversary how about we just sit here
in the living room and watch some TV
while we keep an eye on the kids I mean
sure I guess yeah I guess we could do
that I just got to go make sure one more
time nothing's wrong all right okay I'll
stay right here but don't take too long
you worry too much I know what's going
on here
this game
what was that this game is literally
about Scott coffin the developer of five
nights at freddys interestingly
interesting huh no no free roam in
incoming apparently please respond
immediately who is it
my God's name is going on here oh it's
me Michael look there's no time to
explain just know that you are in grave
danger you stop there with you my
husband has got no he isn't he just went
- what do you mean I'm in danger ma'am I
am very very sorry this is all my fault
you need to stay calm I'll try to help
you through this just please listen to
me very carefully
what listen there are monsters that are
going to arrive to your room real soon
if they see you you are dead
do you understand that man it is very
important that whatever occurs just
don't let them see you alright I
I know I know look just you're in the
living room right try to focus on the
three entrances behind the exit to the
house should be locked and they won't
come through there if there're any
monitors nearby then they should be
forced to produce a camera system for
you ma'am is the TV in your living room
turned on yes but it's filled with
static all right now please keep an eye
on it should help you look they usually
come from either the left side or the
right side you have nothing to stop them
so if you see one of them about to enter
the room just hide hide hide where just
look look just stay out of sight oh okay
yes if they trying to come in just move
somewhere they won't be able to see you
okay
well I don't know which one will come
from which side but if you look at the
TV you might be able to tell by
yourselves
maybe if you can try to see if you can
look through the doors to windows thost
yes keyholes if any of your doors has a
keyhole you can peek through keep
checking it they won't notice you on the
other side trust me
I said so yes I I can't stress this
enough if anything comes through those
doors hide just hide away from view you
might hear noises later on in the night
pay attention to those don't look at
anything that appears in your room and
try to stay safe please do I have to
stay here all night
what about my children what about my
husband
look it's very hard to explain ma'am and
no just wait until 6:00 a.m. to be safe
but don't worry the time will pass much
faster keep an eye on the clock and wait
for that time they should all be gone in
a few minutes and then the hours when we
say no please if you survive I need you
to grab your kids and get out of this
house as soon as possible I'm gonna help
Scott get out of here myself
don't worry just please get yourself and
your sons
out of harm's way I I don't understand
what is even happening how do you know
all this stuff wait wait a second how do
you know my husband's name I was there
when he found you Michael he never said
his name how do you know Michael
okay great yeah this is weird
all right I don't know what it means by
hide there's nowhere to hide here it's a
big empty room where am I gonna go and
we're gonna slide into the bookshelf
we're gonna slip under the couch file
myself away under flubber nocked that's
what I am don't be my name okay these
don't have key holes so I can't exactly
look through it oh boy I don't know
where it wants me to hi what in the
world doesn't mean by that looks bad oh
these look bad oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
Oh bones Oh boned I am oh say can you
see how boned I am in my boy oh boy oh
boy I don't know what I'm supposed to do
about this I've only got foxy and Freddy
on the command screen here no no no what
I'm supposed to do when they get here is
it just the two of them oh they're
coming up to a door Oh God
Oh excuse you what is it I didn't place
it you said that the front door was
gonna be locked oh the front door was
probably the one with the poster on it
oh I'm dumb okay alright that's the one
it's gonna be oh boy every edge there's
gonna be a beverage okay so this is a
front door I still can't honker that
alright so let me think about this
logically oh no it's still paused uh
okay think about this marking move where
logically in this place could you hide
can I turn out the light II lose no I
can't I can't go through there I can't
look in there I can't hide in the only
these shoeboxes
can't hide in the filing cabinet yeah
I'm bowing around is what I am I'm just
purely boned I'm so strongly boned I'm
gonna try to hide on this side of the
room maybe foxy can only see movement
there were two you alrighty then
well that was fun I'm gonna be right
here I'm a I'm gonna give faithful foxy
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna get a
face full of foxy hey buddy
hey I'm where the game hit Oh God is
that doing something is that actually
way way way way way is that actually
doing something how does it work what so
how does it work
am i tapping into their cerebral cortex
does that actually work is that how that
is oh that's how it actually is isn't it
oh my god it is holy [ __ ] okay oh that's
super weird but I think I'm okay I think
I you alrighty then alright so if if I'm
pausing one somehow the other one is
slightly ahead oh that's how you get him
out of rhythm
then if foxy is coming through one door
I can hide from
right weird stopping but alright alright
then if Foxy's coming through this door
then I can hide here from foxy and then
go over there okay oh boy ready boy
ready boy how are you doing Freddy boy I
heard something over there but hey we
did something okay we survived one hour
who do we got and we're okay they're
gonna continually be off rhythm now cuz
it looks like they're gonna continually
be off rhythm now so if they're in that
rhythm maybe they come in at random but
I still don't know what's going on over
here it seems like something bad might
happen over there but so far so goo okay
that must be the baby heard a noise oh
boy okay something back there hi hello
who are you buddy
are you buddy oh my god from Barney I
don't know how I hide from Barney okay
we got incoming though we got in common
places there's no hiding from that oh
boy
Bonnie might be coming down and Bonnie
might bash open those doors and bash in
my skull with a big body oh hello who's
that I don't like the sound of those
noises where's ready where's red ball
oh there is my Fred boy how you doing
welcome to my abode I've got a grave
concern with Bonnie that's bad what was
that look I'm a risk a look oh that's a
bad luck right okay maybe over here is
gonna be okay I don't know I'm probably
boned
excuse you what the hell is that
oh hi Bonnie hi how you doing buddy how
you doing buddy buddy okay all right
then who's wearing who's where and who's
wears who's doing what foxy okay Foxy's
coming up on it
Nepal's Freddy I don't know what the
banging in the van see is is probably
chica butter you know I don't have time
to worry about that long as I can't okay
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go
please don't eat my brains if he comes
anywhere I'm I'll be use okay I think I
can do this
this seems oddly manageable okay it's
weird it is weird don't get me wrong
it's really weird but it works
surprisingly turn that was it dad uh is
that mr. monster okay monsters a ways
away means I got time
all right this next cycle could be
that's that's not a good sound that's
right you just scare me that's okay
don't listen to the noises of the night
chica is a big bit
hi Freddy welcome to the party oh boy I
guess I'm okay ooh
keep on bun right there okay bonbon
right there okay bonbon come on in come
on in bonbon here comes Bonnie
anybody hi welcome okay all right okay
okay okay okay
check out foxy foxy foxy where's foxy
coming down the way okay okay
Foxy's right at the door which is fine
like that okay go go go
good thing chica wasn't there okay we're
doing pretty good hey how's it going
that was you saying how good we were
doing you want to change that fact topic
boy why you want to come in a beer and
[ __ ] up my daddy no bonbon no bonbon yet
which is good which is fine totally fine
where's foxy [ __ ] to come around the
corner she can hopefully not here
there's Freddy they're a good bit
separated which is nice but it seems
like someone might be accelerating if
I'm not mistaken that's that's bad
that's bad okay okay [ __ ] you
go go go
yeah that was close that was too close
Freddy Fred boy that was weird you loose
you know anticipate this no look oh
that's that's bad but not that bad not
as bad as it could be
oh god they're right on top of each
other oh my god oh my god those I almost
ran right into that dorm then foxy might
have known something got here whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay alrighty then
okay think I'm gonna through this she's
got to control him a little bit longer
so breeze
foxy actually Fox he's fine foxy can
come on down cuz that means they're
opposite again Freddy you stay frozen
oh hey don't look that way that'd be bad
whoa what the [ __ ] was that what am i
doing wait whoa whoa whoa whoa that's
way the [ __ ] is that what the [ __ ]
happened what the [ __ ] is happening
excuse you oh my god I don't know what's
happening but I don't like it it's 5:00
a.m. and I'm too close to this to be
bullshitted oh I have eyes on the walls
oh boy he's almost at the door
freeze foxy just a little bit longer
I think those okay I think that actually
might have an oh don't get [ __ ] by
that Oh God
oh god I'm [ __ ]
I think it'll be foxy first but I'm not
sure Hey it was foxy first okay that I'm
just gonna tuck in that corner go away
go away go away no no no no go go go
okay think that is gonna be
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] where's Freddie
where's Freddie where's Freddie okay
Freddie right there
go Freddy go Freddy go Freddy go go man
as soon as Freddy goes I'm diving in
that corner in the fab 5 Freddy go go go
go Freddy go Freddy go Freddy go Freddy
go go go Freddy go increase the haunted
woods increase paranormal sightings near
the countryside sparks interest over a
full investigation else nerve-wracking
that was nerve-wracking those nerve
wrecking I'm like I'm so twitchy ready
oh okay but I did it I did it I did it
okay it's really hard but the mechanics
are good like it's interesting like
these mechanics are interesting because
I've never seen him before in a five
guys - Freddy's game anyway or a nanny
game I guess man good [ __ ] though good
[ __ ] good [ __ ] good [ __ ] so anyway that
is all for the living room that was a
challenge but I got through it okay next
up is oh the office so anyway that is
the living room the office is up next so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought of this
down in the comments below and as always
I will see
in the next video
[Music]